YUFENG GUO: Keeras?
Kaaris?
Kras?
Keras?
Carrots?
Keras.
What is Keras, and
how can you use
it to get started creating your
own machine learning models?
Stay tuned to find out.
[ELECTRONIC BEEPING]
Welcome to Cloud AI
Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode
of AI Adventures,
I'll show you how to get started
with Keras in the quickest way
possible.
It's never been easier to
get started with Keras.
Not only is Keras
built into TensorFlow
via tensorflow.keras,
you also don't even
have to install or
configure anything
if you use a tool
like Kaggle Kernels.
All you need to do is create
your Kaggle account if needed
and sign in.
Then you have access to all
that Keras has to offer.
Keras also exists as
a standalone library,
but the TensorFlow version
has the exact same APIs
and some extra features.
Let's head over to
my Kaggle Kernel,
where I'll show you how to get
started using Keras right now.
In a previous episode, we
did some machine learning
on the dataset Fashion-MNST.
It's a dataset of 10 different
types of fashionable items,
from pants and shirts
to shoes and handbags,
all presented in 28
by 28 pixel grayscale.
Mmm, grayscale.
Today, we'll do a similar
analysis using Keras.
So to use Keras, we'll just
import TensorFlow like usual.
These imports are
actually identical to what
we had before.
And we'll pull in numpy,
and pandas, and natplotlib
just as we normally would.
And we continue operating
kind of in the usual way.
We'll pull in our
training and test CSVs
and load them up in
pandas and take a look
at what they look like.
We've got our Label
column on the far left
with numbers from
zero through nine.
And we have our Pixels--
pixel 1, 2, 3, all the
way up to pixel 784.
I've got a function
here to preprocess
our data a little bit.
It's similar to
what we had before.
I've just cleaned it up and
made it a little more concise.
I'm pulling out the features
and dividing by 255,
so we normalize all
the grayscale values
to be between zero and one.
And I'll pull out
the labels as well
and have them both be
represented as an numpy arrays.
We use that function to pull
out our training and test
data from the data
frame and associate them
to explicit variables--
train_features
and train_labels,
test_features and test_labels.
And we can see that the final
shape of these variables
are exactly as we would expect--
60,000 examples
with 784 columns.
And then our labels are
just the 60,000 values.
And we're going to take
a peek at one of them.
This is our 20th
training_feature set.
And some pixels
in the middle, we
can see that they're indeed
values between zero and one.
And we can also visualize it.
Here we have a shirt, and we
can see that it looks exactly
as you'd expect--
kind of grainy and grayscale.
Now, with Keras in
this particular case,
we're going to need to
one-hot hot encode our data.
And what that means is we're
going to take our training
labels, which used to be just
values like zero, three, seven,
and turn them into--
each of them-- into
an array of length 10.
All 10 values in the array will
be zeros except for one value.
That one value will be a 1.
And so that's why it's
called one-hot encoding.
Now, where is that one located?
It's going to be exactly the
number that it came from.
So, for example, if
the value was seven,
the seventh zero will be a one.
If the number was four, then
the fourth zero will be a one--
hence one-hot encoding.
And so we'll run Keras
wtils.to_categorical,
which is a handy utility
function that will just do this
for us.
And we'll observe that
the train labels have now
turned from 60,000
rows of numbers
to 60,000 rows with 10 columns.
And we can see that indeed, in
that same example label that we
saw before now, the
zeroth index has a 1,
and everything else
remains a zero.
And now comes the really fun
part of working with Keras--
creating our model.
Keras supplies a really
easy and intuitive way
to build up your model
from the ground up.
In this case, we're going
to make a sequential model
and add layers on top of it.
The first letter we'll
have has 30 nodes
and has an activation function
of a rectified linear unit
for relu, which in the case of
TensorFlow that we used before,
was the default
activation function.
Then we'll have another
fully-connected layer
or dense layer with
20 neurons, this time
also with a relu function.
And finally, we'll do our
final mapping to the 10 output
values of zero through
nine and have an activation
of the softmax, which
basically just distributes
power probabilities
across the 10 buckets.
And now we're ready
to compile our model.
Keras uses this
notation of compiling
a model as similar to
when you do something
like string builder or
something to just say, I'm done.
Put it all together for me.
And we'll supply a loss,
optimizer, and metrics
for what kind of values we
want to get out of it, for how
to optimize for the
best values, as well as
how we want to measure loss.
In this case, we're using
categorical cross entropy
because our outputs
are categorical.
And cross entropy, in this
case, happens to be a nice way
to measure our loss or error.
With our model created,
we're ready to run training.
Training with Keras is
as easy as calling .fit.
When we call .fit, all
we need to supply are
the training_features
and training_labels.
It's also a good idea to
supply epochs and batch_size
so that we can control the
training a little more.
In this case, we have
supplied an epoch
of two, which means we'll go
through the entire dataset
twice over.
And we'll supply a
batch_size of 128.
This means that with
each training step,
the model will see 128
examples which will help guide
it to adjust its parameters.
And so we can see here Keras
has some really useful helpless
as the training
happens and gives us
a sense of the progress.
It also then prints out
the loss and accuracy
at the end of each epoch.
But seeing the accuracy at the
end loss at the end of training
isn't nearly as
useful as evaluation.
We need to see the accuracy
against our actual test
dataset.
So let's call our
model.evaluate function
and this time pass in our
test_features and test_labels.
This will give us an
accuracy, and we can
print that out and take a look.
We can see we got
84.7% accuracy.
And of course, we
could certainly
do better than that
with increased epochs,
a more sophisticated model,
and other approaches.
But this is just
an intro to Keras.
And hopefully, this will give
you a good starting point
to start playing
around with Keras
and seeing all
that Keras can do.
Keras has an amazing
community and lots
of samples which,
when you combine
with Kaggle's
community, gives you
a truly epic set of resources to
get you started the right way.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed
it, please like it
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
Now, what are you waiting for?
Head on over to Kaggle and
start playing around with Keras
today.